if you were looking forward to Mass  Effect Andromeda multiplayer tech test  I've got some disappointing news I'm  Tony this is a game spot news update and  for all the latest on mass effect be  sure to subscribe Andromeda's  multiplayer tech test has been canceled  producer Fernando mellow took to Twitter  to apologize and explain why he said  sorry we won't have a multiplayer  technical test I know many we're looking  forward to it as were we long story but  right decision for how close we are to  going live Mass Effect Andromeda small t  player has had the most extensive user  testing we've ever done it's a bummer  for sure but Mass Effect Andromeda will  still be launching on March 21st for ps4  xbox one and pc and Mello said there's  still more multiplayer news to come if  you want to learn about another RPG in  the meantime you can check out our  legend of zelda breath of the wild  review right now we're all the latest on  all the RPGs you're already in the right  place